Prends le bout de papier.
Et t'écris le numéro de ton père.
Allez.
Allez, dépêche-toi !
Allô ?
Ecoute-moi bien parce que je le répèterai pas deux fois.
Ecoute-moi bien parce que je le répèterai pas deux fois !
On tient ton fils en otage, ok ?
N'essaie pas d'appeler la police.
Sinon on le bute direct, ok ?
On veut 150 000 euros en petites coupures.
Sinon on le bute.
Mon fils ?
Ton fils, oui.
Mais il est en face de moi.
Comment ça il est en face de toi ?
Allô ?
Il a raccroché.
Quoi ?
Il nous mythonne.
Te fous pas de ma gueule !
C'est bien le numéro de ton père ça ?
Non.
Non ?
Ouais non mais attends, j'ai... ouais !
J'ai confondu parce que...
Ah j'ai confondu le 1 et le 7 !
Ouais.
Non mais attends, t'as vu comment il écrit aussi là ?
Regarde là ! On t'a pas appris à écrire à l'école ?
C'est des pattes de mouches sont truc.
Non, non, c'est clairement un 7 là.
Ça se voit que c'est un 7.
Tu veux pas être de mon côté pour une fois là ?
Bon, donne-moi ça.
Ouais.
Tu fais mieux toi.
Tiens.
Allô ?
Oui, bonjour.
Je suis bien au 07 61 55 81 10 ?
Oui.
Ouais ?
Super.
Ecoute-moi bien parce que je le répèterai pas deux fois.
On tient ton fils en otage, n'essaie pas d'appeler la police...
Sinon on le bute direct.
On veut... 50 000 euros...
150 ! On veut 150 000 !
T'es con ou quoi ?! On a dit 150 !
150 000 euros...
En...
En petites coupures ?
Bon, passe-moi ça, passe-moi-ça.
Ecoute-moi bien.
On a ton fils en otage.
Si tu nous files pas 150 000 euros...
On va lui faire très mal.
On va lui péter les deux genoux.
Et après tu sais ce qu'on va lui faire ?
Non ?
Et bah je te donne un indice !
T'es malade ! Mais chut...
Tu vas nous faire repérer.
Qu'est ce qu'il dit ?
Il dit...
Il dit que t'es qu'un petit con.
Ah bon ?
Un petit con qu'a jamais rien foutu.
Que ta mémé elle aurait honte de toi.
Et que tu peux te foutre l'héritage au cul.
Oh !
Ah, il rigole pas.
Il propose 20 balles.
Il a raccroché.
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave.
Moi, mon père, il m'a jamais dit je t'aime, ok ?
Et regarde où on en est maintenant, hein ?
Started from the bottom now we're here, hein ?
Rappelle-le.
Bah non, non je vais pas le rappeler.
Franchement il avait l'air énervé, non.
Ok le rappelle pas.
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave.
On va appeler ta mère.
File-nous son numéro.
Hein ? Attends... Attends...
Non pas ma mère.
Pitié pas ma mère.
Pourquoi ?
Parce qu'elle va me tuer si elle apprend que je suis là...
Je lui ai promis de pas sortir et de réviser mes partiels.
Ok !
Ok, donc nous on a des flingues...
Et c'est ta mère qui te fait peur ?
Passe-moi le numéro de ta mère, merde !
Putain ! Mais bibou !
Non mais vraiment, ça sert à rien ! Ma mère elle est à sec !
Mon père, il lui a rien laissé après le divorce !
Oh non. Ça c'est relou ça !
Merde.
Bon. Ok.
T'as bien quelqu'un qui t'aime un peu dans ta famille ?
Je sais pas...
Une grand-mère un peu friquée...
Qui voudrait bien payer pour te sauver la vie.
Et, nous sauver la vie accessoirement.
Parce que...
Eh oui !
Notre boss, elle va nous tuer si on ramène pas la thune.
Bah non mais mes grands-parents ils sont morts.
Oh non ! Comment ?
Merde...
Non mais attend, c'est super triste là.
Mais non, c'est pas triste !
Moi aussi ils sont morts mes grands-parents !
Je vais très bien !
Ah bibou, t'as plus tes grands-parents ?
Oh merde...
C'est pour ça que tu me les as jamais présenté, en fait ?
Pourquoi t'ouvres la bouche toi, en fait ?
Pourquoi t'essayes de parler ?
Moi j'essaye de nous sortir de là, j'essaye de trouver une solution et toi...
Toi, tu...
Parle !
C'est chiant !
Non mais c'est triste...
Bon, on reprend.
A la limite, toi, t'as pas des thunes ?
Si, je crois que j'ai 20 balles.
Oh bah...
Non... Il me reste plus que 6,50...
Parce que j'ai payé un kebab, du coup...
Un kebab à 13,50, donc ?
Ah oui, c'était une assiette.
Ok. Passe toujours, passe toujours.
Police !
C'est quoi ça ? C'est quoi ça ?
On s'est fait repérer !
Mais c'est toi, t'as fait trop de bruit !
Police ! Ouvrez la porte !
Faut trouver une solution !
Il faut sortir de là !
La fenêtre ! La fenêtre !
Quelle fenêtre ? On est dans une putain de cave !
Y a pas de fenêtre !
Ouvre la porte !
Merde !
Ouvre !
Moi j'ai peut-être une idée.
Police ! Personne ne bouge !
C'est pas nous ! C'est pas nous ! C'est pas nous !
Ok. Situation sous contrôle.
Aucune trace des ravisseurs et pas de blessés parmi les otages.
En fait ce qu'il s'est passé c'est que... On était dans la rue...
Puis on a vu un type sortir d'une camionnette...
Puis enlever Lucas.
Le type, enfin le ravisseur, il nous a vu...
Mais ta gueule, putain.
Il nous a braqué avec un flingue...
Et c'est pour ça qu'on est attachés ici.
Hein Lucas ? C'est vrai ?
Euh...
Oui !
C'est vrai tout ce qu'on vous raconte hein.
On est des otages.
Ok.
On a jamais dit le contraire.
Ça va ?
Ça va... On s'est fait kidnapper...
J'ai bien compris ça.
Faut appeler la boss.
Et la prévenir que ça c'est pas passé comme prévu.
Ok. Tu l'appelles ?
Je l'appelle.
Oui ?
Allô...
Oh !
Oh ! Pardon madame !
Excusez-moi, pardon.
Je me suis trompé.
Bonne soirée.
Je me suis encore trompé.
Mais c'est mon téléphone aussi. Il déconne là.
J'ai pas dû faire la MAJ.
C'est la boss !
Elle appelle ! Qu'est ce que je lui dis ?
T'as rien compris, espèce de débile !
Mais c'est sa mère la boss !
Allô ?
Vous avez tout fait foirer bande de con.
Je veux plus jamais entendre parler de vous.
Attends, y avez combien de pour cent de chance pour que la boss ça soit la mère de Lucas ?
On a pas de pot.
Rappelle-moi...
Pourquoi je t'aime toi en fait ?
Tu vois ton père c'est vraiment un crevard.
Mais alors les deux là, c'est vraiment des blaireaux.
On rentre ?
Oui.
Il pèle, non ?
Eh, la semaine prochaine on se tenterait pas tati du sud ?
Elle est pleine de thune et elle m'adore.
Oh ouais !
Ouais !
Ça me plaît ça !
Elle est naïve en plus !
Très naïve !